this video is brought to you by nordvpn
training is many things to many people
but for me one of the main reasons to
train is to increase your freedom
through Fitness we gain freedom in a
very literal sense physical Freedom the
freedom to move as we choose Freedom
From Pain freedom to travel further
faster to see and do more to increase
the number of options we have at any
given moment
perhaps this is why I run everywhere I
go why walk to the shops when you can
make getting there quicker and more fun
by jogging instead but of course this
requires a bit of cardio
being faster and having better Fitness
allows me to cover more ground do more
in less time and see more when I go out
jogging I don't pick a route first I
just explore
where I live it is fairly flat terrain
but hypothetically if I came across an
obstacle like a boulder or a sheer climb
with a greater strength to weight ratio
I could overcome it quickly if I wanted
to go off the beaten path to climb a
tree I can do that and then get an
amazing view of my surroundings if I
want to crawl into a small space to
explore a cave or the hollowed out
insides of an old tree I can do that too
all of this requires Mobility endurance
and strength it's those things that let
us rise above the noise
of course there are a few better
expressions of this physical freedom
than parkour it's saying no to narrow
Pavements and crowded streets it's
saying no to being hemmed in and yes to
Soaring like a bird
there are some people who unfortunately
lack the mobility and are in too much
pain to move as they would choose so we
should never take our fitness and our
Mobility for granted and in fact we
should do as much as we can to expand it
whilst we can
being able to move well is critical for
self-expression too the most obvious
example of this is dance Dance is a
display of physical Freedom allowing us
to demonstrate our true emotions and
feelings through the way we move in fact
almost any form of training is a form of
self-expression
speaking of technology that empowers and
grants you Freedom there are a few
better examples than a VPN like today's
sponsor nordvpn nordvpn helps you to
surf the web with greater security and
greater Freedom it does this by letting
you reroute your traffic via their
servers so that your location and
browsing activity remain hidden this has
several key advantages not only does it
let you appear as though you're browsing
from another country literally
increasing your freedom by giving you
access to region locks content but it
also keeps your private data safe a VPN
can keep you safe from multiple common
types of attack consider a
man-in-the-middle attack let's say
you're connected to a coffee shop Wi-Fi
called coffee Wi-Fi and happily browsing
the web
only that's not the name of their Wi-Fi
turns out you're in fact connected to
Wi-Fi hosted by the Shady guy in the
corner of the room you can now see
everything that you're looking at the
good news if you're using nordvpn then
the nefarious nerdywell won't see any of
that all they'll see is that you're
connected to one of their servers
everything beyond that is obfuscated
there are countless more ways that
nordvpn can help you protect your data
and keep you safe on the web so to learn
more visit nordvpn.com and if you use
the link in the description you'll also
be entitled to four months free with any
two-year subscription and a 30-day
money-back guarantee
thanks once again to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video and now on with
the show the way you move and even the
way you sit or stand when not in motion
says a huge amount
what is your body saying right now Bruce
Lee explained how honing himself
physically allowed him to express
himself authentically so that when he
wanted it it was there
honestly expressing yourself
so we shouldn't view Fitness as
restrictive or confining it's not a
means to overpowering others it's not a
set of rigid requirements with
inflexible rules Fitness is
self-expression Fitness allows us to
become the fullest version of ourselves
there are a few specific ways we can
train with this freedom in Mind by
training in multiple disciplines for
example we create more options the
option to be strong and move the objects
blocking our path to be agile and to
climb over it or to be fast and go
around it of course emphasizing and
prioritizing movement also goes hand in
hand with this Freedom as does placing
some emphasis on endurance but think as
well about how you might use your
Fitness outside of your training are you
expressing yourself physically in your
daily life are you utilizing your body
to its fullest potential are you using
that Fitness at all
and are you dressed ready for movement
if you're wearing work shoes with a
thick sole high heels and a cramped toe
box then I'd argue not if your jeans are
too tight for you to squat I'd argue not
could you break into a run right now if
you wanted to and if not what's the
point of being able to run so well
the same goes for having so much stuffed
into your pockets that you can't even
jump these are easily remedied by a
light shoulder bag jeans with a stretch
fabric which is yes why you see me doing
squats in my jeans and barefoot shoes
what you wear and carry with you is a
technology and to me technology should
only be an extension of the
self-expression and freedom
foreign too often we view technology as
a means to being more productive when a
new computer comes out we might laud it
for how much more work it will allow us
to do
instead I like to reframe my gadgets as
tools for creativity and once again
self-expression technology has allowed
me to create things and share those
things with people in ways that would
never have been possible
technology when used correctly can even
unshackle us from our desks this is why
I love tiny laptops I can throw my GPD
winmax 2 in the smallest bag possible go
for a run find a Scenic spot and then
stop there to do some typing when I
lived in London I'd sometimes work with
views of Saint Paul's on roof bars or in
Camden Market these days I work in my
own office where I've got a bunch of
things I can work out with
there are digital Nomads right now using
technology to explore the world while
making a living and I even sampled a
little bit of that lifestyle myself when
I was younger
whereas today that freedom allows me to
spend more time with my family even when
you aren't using technology to escape
with the confines of an office it can be
used to move more instead of less and
all this makes sense when you consider
that technology is also an extension of
yourself it's time to start making your
Fitness and your technology work for you
instead of the other way around forget
training because you're supposed to
forget using technology to work longer
and longer hours set a course for the
kind of body and self-expression that's
authentic to you and then go after it
so if you found this video useful
interesting guys a little bit different
than usual just a another little
training philosophy as people seem to
generally like those
if you're looking for a training program
are designed to help you move better and
faster for longer then you might enjoy
my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 the protein
performance system that combines
multiple different training Styles into
a single program designed to build not
only your speed but your Mobility your
strength your endurance even brain
function
it comes with over two hours of
instructional video and an 80 plus page
ebook so check it out
big thank you to Liam Ellis of
perception media who helped me shoot
this one if you want to check out his
work and I do highly recommend his work
then I'll leave a link to his website in
the description down below as well
either way guys thank you so much for
watching this one and I'll see you next
time
bye for now